the new iphone is always the most
anticipated phone of the year the iphone
13 was launched in september just four
months ago and with its launch we saw
some of the biggest upgrades the iphone
had since the iphone x now it's time for
the iphone 14 and although it might seem
like the iphone 13 was just launched
yesterday we've already got a
significant amount of information on the
iphone 14. from leaks to renders there's
a lot to cover on this upcoming beauty
so without further ado let's dive right
in
line up and display size first up we
have the size let's be honest apple's
naming scheme hasn't really been the
easiest to understand and when it came
to pronunciation the xs max suffered was
it xs or was it xs we'll never know this
year apple has decided to make it even
more confusing there's rumored to be a
new size option in the iphone 14 lineup
called the iphone 14 max it's going to
be the same display size as the iphone
14 pro max but without any of the pro
capabilities this one is for the people
that wanted the larger display size of
the pro version but weren't willing to
shell out an extra two to three hundred
dollars for it the iphone 14 will have
inferior hardware but as we've seen with
the iphone 13 mini apple does a pretty
good job of optimizing the phone even if
its hardware isn't bleeding edge the
updated line would then consist of the
iphone 14 the iphone 14 pro iphone 14
max and finally the iphone 14 pro max
the exact display size is rumored to be
6.7 inches for the iphone 14 max and
iphone 14 pro max and 6.1 inches for the
iphone 14 and iphone 14 pro according to
mac rumors talking about the mini this
would be a good time to mention that
there's not going to be a mini version
anymore yes you heard that right the
iphone 14 lineup is not going to have
the mini version this is because of bad
sales with the previous mini versions
although the iphone 12 mini and the
iphone 13 mini were the best deals that
apple offered they both had surprisingly
bad sales and now apple has just decided
to discontinue it next up we've got the
much awaited camera redesign
front-facing camera redesign the iphone
notch is cool said no one ever sure it
was a revolutionary step when the iphone
x was released but since then there has
been no major change in the design for
the last three generations the only
difference has been a slight decrease in
the size of the notch but apart from
that there hasn't really been any
improvement in this area androids on the
other hand have explored everything from
pop-up selfie cameras revolving cameras
screen cutouts and even under display
ones sure you can say that apple doesn't
try wild and wacky ideas but even still
we should have seen some improvements in
the design by now it seems like 2022
might just be the year we get to see
that as it's being rumored that apple is
going to go with a hole punch camera
design this year let us know down in the
comments which design you're into should
apple stick with a notch or is the hole
punch the way to go coming back to the
topic regarding how apple is going to
get rid of the notch without getting rid
of face id according to mark german's
power on newsletter for bloomberg apple
is working on improving face id so that
the sensors can be placed under the
screen as for the camera that is still
going to be a screen cutout since let's
be honest the under display ones offer
an irredeemable decrease in camera
quality and the technology just isn't
mature enough for mainstream phones
right now if you were one of the people
that were hoping that apple might bring
back touch id with under display
fingerprint sensors i'm afraid that's
not going to happen at least not in the
iphone 14 lineup this is because optical
under display scanners aren't fully
secure and the supersonic ones are a bit
slow as we've already seen with the
samsung s21 ultra which despite a
high-end chipset has a significantly
slow fingerprint sensor back redesign
the front camera isn't the only thing
getting a redesign the iphone 14 is also
getting a back redesign if you've seen
the latest s22 leaks you know that
samsung is going with a lens implanted
directly into the frame look rather than
a separate raised camera bump apple is
rumored to be doing the same taking
inspiration from the iphone 4 rather
than from samsung while it's hard to
believe that apple would make the iphone
thicker just to get rid of the camera
bump what is most likely to happen is
that apple is going to just add lenses
directly to slightly reduce the camera
protruding from the back personally i
would love it if it ends up looking like
the iphone 4. however if it's anything
like the samsung leaks that's a hard
pass maybe the design will grow on me
once i use it but as of right now i'd
wish apple doesn't try the samsung
approach titanium casting let's talk
about the body before we get to the
internals the new iphone 14 at least the
pro models are going to come with the
titanium casting apple was already ahead
of the competition in terms of build
quality and was using stainless steel
while others were still on aluminum
frames the jump towards the titanium
casting is a big leap and while it does
offer quite a bit of protection it's
also going to increase the price now i
know what you're thinking about whether
the titanium will help in heat
dissipation and the answer is no the
titanium casting is just there for
increased protection and reduced weight
something which the pro models
desperately need for thermal dissipation
apple has been said to be testing a
vapor cooling chamber vapor cooling
chambers have so far been limited to
either gaming phones or really high-end
ones while apple does check the high-end
chipset box they don't really need a
vapor cooling chamber since the bionic
chipset series has the industry's best
optimization and apple has never really
faced any overheating or thermal
throttling issues the introduction of
the vapor chamber cooling system means
that this year we're going to see a
significant improvement in the
processing power of the a16 bionic
chipset apple has always had better
performance in terms of raw processing
power but lagged a bit in app launch
times unloading this year we might see
apple finally catch up to android on
that let's wait and see how that goes
the internals with the design and body
done it's time to jump into the
internals the iphone 14 is coming with
the a16 bionic
[Music]
now there are two possibilities and both
have credible sources i'll let you know
which one i lean towards after i've told
you both first is the a16 bionic being
based on a 4 nanometer chip
manufacturing process you might be
thinking that's obviously what's going
to happen since that's what every
manufacturer has been trying to do this
was first claimed by digitimes and was
what everyone thought was going to
happen the next possibility and
unfortunately the more likely one is
that we're going to see a 5 nanometer
chip for the third year in a row from
apple this news comes from a report by
tsmc themselves according to the report
the new chip is going to be a 5
nanometer one but with a more efficient
building process the report claims some
performance improvements however these
improvements aren't going to translate
much into the iphone's performance since
apple was already using them what this
means is that the a16 might not be
really as powerful as we thought we're
just going to have to wait and see what
happens in this department since nothing
is for certain yet i would love to see a
smaller chip with better performance so
fingers crossed on that
battery
finally we've got the most important
parts of the iphone the battery and the
ever mighty iphone according to your
tsmc report the new chip is supposedly
10 more powerful as compared to the
previous iphone 13 chip this might not
sound like a big deal but keep in mind
that apple has already blown basically
every other brand out of the water with
its battery life a 10 increase in
battery life means that you'll never
have to worry about battery ever again
which to be honest apple has already
achieved with the a15 bionic new camera
system moving on it's time for the
camera apple has reportedly been working
on a new camera system according to mac
rumors we're expecting improvements to
the ultra wide lens and there's a
possibility that the iphone 14 could get
a periscope lens that allows for greater
optical zoom but it's not clear if it's
slated for 2022 or 2023. according to
some other sources apple is probably
going to release the periscope lens in
2023 since as of right now they're
facing some difficulties with patents
that samsung owns there are rumors
however that apple is either going to
pay a small licensing fee or develop a
workaround all this remains to be seen
yet an improvement on the ultra wide is
also much needed since androids are
currently offering way better viewing
angles although they do suffer in video
and with that we are done make sure to
drop a comment to let us know if you
know about any other leaks if you've
been wondering what it's like inside
apple's five billion dollar headquarters
then check out the video right here on
the screen also don't forget to like the
video and subscribe to our channel for
more amazing stuff till then adios